allez vas-y morts - si tu peux
hassam si une centaine de familles
vivent encore d'un métier qui demande
beaucoup de sang froid les hommes sont
chasseurs et charmeurs de serpents
ali le chasseur le plus expérimenté du
village enseigne au dernier de ses six
enfants comment charmer le cobra il en
va de la survie futur de la famille
j'habite eu déjà mon fils de 3 ans cobra
le venin du cobra provoque la mort en
quelques minutes celui du cobra royal
est tellement toxique qu'une seule
morsure peut terrasser un éléphant il
n'y a pas de risque pour monfils
sinon je ne mettrai pas si près du
serpent
je sais exactement à quel moment une
barre tactile et il attaque seulement
quand on la grèce
là le cobra est calme il prend le soleil
mon fils est calme aussi il apprend ça
lui donne du courage de la confiance en
un